battlefield 1 it's almost here comes out
October 21st starting today October 12
we've actually seen it become available
on ei early access a day ahead of when
it was supposed to be available you can
only play for 10 hours only include
certain maps but you still get a nice
sneak preview of the game but where it
comes out next week I'm here with
Spencer Mulder who has played the game
even prior to today so just to start kin
tell us about your experience with the
game I understand you were at a press
event last week and got a chance to play
like what 8 or 9 hours of the game
something like that yeah so last week we
went to I went to a press event in LA
for dices main headquarters so got about
9 hours in and right off the bat the
biggest draw I got from that game where
the maps to maps for example almost
called arms which actually takes place
in the urban chaos of Germany and then
you go to st. Quinton scar which then
takes place in the countryside of France
where there's trenches everywhere and
the whole thing just really kind of
brought me into that experience of being
in World War one which I haven't had
that kind of experience since Bad
Company 2 and it really is just amazing
really grew up feeling like you really
feel like you're there in that type of
historical battles instead of running
around in fictional combat zones
fighting Russia again in past
battlefield games you could do like five
or six games ago so it was really
awesome I'm sure we'll find some reason
to fight Russia but so it's interesting
to hear you say that it felt more like
older battlefield games and not less
like hardline or some of the more recent
stuff they've been trying mean who is
there anything else like what about the
experience made you feel like it was
more in line with like traditional
battlefield games well the traditional
thing about battlefield games is that
they started off in obviously in World
War 2 and then they moved forward on to
modern combat the thing about modern
combat was that we've all experienced
mark I'm about too many times I think
about world war 1 is that it's a very
lightly touched subject in games and in
here they capture the real feel and I've
got to say horror as well because you
are seeing guys die left and right in
the most crazy you know unexpectable
ways you can imagine and the game itself
really kind of captures that notion and
more and more so are the maps and even
the behemoths which are these giant
vehicle monstrosity that show up giving
in and being a Zeppelin a battleship or
a train and you
pilot these things as well so you're
just raining down Hellfire on your
opponents and just destroying these
beautiful maps and full destruction
which we I so much in so many of the
other past battlefield games and it's
here in full beauty and it's amazing
it's awesome
so it has the destruction actually like
improved or increased sense the beta's
again is the final version actually more
detail than what we played previously
you're kidding jealous even just a
little bit more about how destruction
works in in battlefield one I think it's
increased since the beta it's definitely
surpassed anything that we've had
previously like in battlefield 3 for and
in hard lines for sure for example when
I was piloting the Zeppelin I was coming
over a house and in the house of so much
enemies run in who were about to shoot
at my allies running down a hill as we
were pushing the objective
I dropped a set of bombs and you can do
when you're pedaling the Zeppelin and
that blew open the house to pieces but
because where the bombs fell the
destruction physics reacted to where the
explosion was seeing bad company - they
didn't do that no matter what explosion
you used the house would always crumble
the same way right and here if you blow
up on the left or the right the house
reacts to that that is so cool and you
just you can imagine the look on
people's faces when they think they got
a good eye of a window and the whole
house just crumbles right past them and
it's the little details it's like the
little things that they did with this
game that's just blowing everybody away
the destruction and the sound definitely
so you open by talking about the maps
and how sort of different and how
immersive the maps are what about the
game modes it's another really important
staple of the Battlefield series
interesting game modes unique specific
game modes to the series can tell us
about the MOSI you played last week I
think the best mode that people can get
a kick out of is operations operations
is a cross between rush and conquests
this mode I kid you not is where some of
those hectic battles happen and the idea
of this is that you have battle sections
and in each battle section has two to
three different flags inside of it so
you're not arming crates like you would
and rush but unlike conquest where
you're running all over the map sits on
a certain section every single time and
so it's more you know congested it's a
lot more tight close quarters combat
it's better for I guess you say squad
communication
you can also lone wolf-- if you want but
if operations just has that real cool
feel that we haven't really experienced
in in my opinion since rush came out
back on Bad Company one so it's really
amazing stuff and it had such a blast
playing ourselves like overall you're
feeling pretty positive about the game
oh yeah no I feel very positive about
the game I mean I'm a battlefield that
I've been playing since partnered combat
back on the original xbox all all
throughout the series since then and as
I said this game to me I think is gonna
be they did it right so well done in the
week in the week ahead of launch do you
have any concerns about him is there
anything left you still I kind of need
to know or are you just completely sold
at this point I do have a little bit of
a concern and it's with the operations
mode it's great don't get me wrong it
really is a lot of fun however in the
each match consists of three rounds
right so in the last two rounds the
behemoth regardless of what it is comes
back for the attacking team if the
defending team gets to hold them off
each and every battle section or so and
the thing that though about for me is
that to have the behemoth show up on the
third round it's a little bit of an
overkill because when you get it the
second round the attacking team can
basically push the defending team all
the way to almost their last base and if
they destroy it and hold them off to
have the attacking team get that thing
again it's really kind of like yeah
we're got that we can see how the
community feels about it but for me
personally it's like okay we finally
brought that thing down end of round 2
awesome we can totally win this out
round 3 the thing comes flying in or
training in or whatever your psyche man
getting punished for succeeding in a
yeah yeah this is not it I mean like
well said we'll have to see how the
community acts to it but it's it's a
little it's a little bit of a bummer to
have to deal with but it's not to say
you can't destroy it again it's just a
little extra work and you really need
tight team coordination to pull it off
gotcha all right we'll let that I think
says everything we need to say so if you
want to read more about battlefield 4
stick around and gamespot.com for
further coverage of battlefield and
everything else coming out the solidus
season
yeah we have taken objective salsa